so again
welcome everyone um this is our workshop
on closing the year with the bang um my
name is yvonne fleur marugu
i go by um yvonne and i'm one of the
udacity career coaches
so just a little bit about me um
so i'm a passionate career coach whose
work
is centered around getting my clients to
determine what they're most passionate
about defining or
redefining their why then creating a
fulfilling and purpose-driven career and
going after those seemingly
impossible dreams so
for me really my switch over
into career um came after about
a 15-year career in human resources and
recruiting
um i spent it after about 10 12 years i
started getting the itch that this is
not what i wanted to do in my life this
is not you know i was no longer feeling
purposeful i
no longer felt that i was growing um yes
i had reached um
most of the career milestones that i
wanted i had reached
director level i was um i was
running hr for multiple regions i've
worked you know
several places globally as well as in
the us but i had this
nagging need that i wasn't feeling
purposeful in my day-to-day
um i had you know i was making all the
money i you know i had all the status i
had the position
but i wasn't where i wanted to be and
then and really looking back in my life
and what really
fulfilled me and where i felt most at
home was when i was
in the space of being able to positively
contribute
in people's lives and whether it's you
know advice from
you know any aspect of life whether it's
life coaching career coaching holistic
health and wellness
um which are all you know passionate
areas of mind so career coaching came
naturally to me just because of my
background in hr recruitment
and i've been with udacity for about a
year now i absolutely love or a little
bit of
actually over a year and i absolutely
love working with the students
you know mo we're unique where most
students are looking to
either pivot into something new
or examining what it is that they want
to do
or kind of you know just just looking
for change so it's it's normally some of
the best
places to start the coaching process so
welcome welcome welcome i'm very very
happy to have you here
and we can go ahead and get started um
and again for anyone new who has come in
feel free to introduce yourself in the
chat and just some um
some important things for the webinar um
the more you're able to focus and engage
the more you'll be able to get out of it
i'll have lots of opportunities for us
to engage you're welcome to unmute
yourself and speak up
or use the chat whichever one you prefer
but the more we can all engage as a
group we have a
you know a decent size i like to keep my
webinars a little bit smaller so just
that way i'm able to engage more um
we'll have a lot more time for questions
in the end as well so definitely i will
really appreciate your involvement as we
go along
um so going over today's agenda
obviously we'll speak about
um uh why we're here you know which is
um the um
really going over our year closing our
year with the bank and then seeing how
we can bring that
into 2021 so first we'll start with
reviewing the year we're examining the
goals that we had for 2020
and then reviewing some key
accomplishments and challenges and
learnings that we took from this
very very interesting year that we had
we may have a breakout session or we may
just have an open we have a small enough
group where we may just be able to have
an
open session and speaking about some of
our greatest learnings for 2020
and then the roadmap for 2021 which is
really setting up
what do we want out of 2021
what are some of the goals that we're
unable to achieve in 2020 that we can
kind of
now set ourselves up um to do in 21
and then also reviewing um visioning and
smart go
actually smarter go go setting um which
will
also be key in ensuring that you're able
to meet your goals
and then obviously we'll have a q a at
the end and you're welcome to also ask
your questions as we go along um you can
uh type them into the chat or you can
speak up
on just on you you should all be able to
mute yourself and speak up
um so you are welcome to do that
so welcome again to any new guest thank
you abdul rahman from
india great we have austria amazing so i
love that we have such diversity earlier
we had san francisco london
chicago arizona i i again i'm in sunny
washington dc it's a little bit cool but
it's sunny so
definitely a great day so let's go on to
the next slide
so our year in review we have had quite
a year
um one for the history books we've had a
global pandemic
we've had a financial crisis as a result
of it
we've had political and social uprisings
especially for us in the us
and then obviously there's a uh
a job market slump in some sectors you
know some sectors are doing really well
and then we have some sectors you know
like hospitality like tourism and travel
like the airlines that really took a hit
so definitely um
has been an interesting year
so i'd love to um to see
you know in seeing how we've kind of
made it out
of or how we're making out of 2020
where were you at the start of the year
what were your goals what were some of
your intentions
um for this year and how
you know in thinking about your
intentions at the start
how many achievements or how much were
you able to accomplish versus the
hurdles and really what are we able
to learn and take away because
you know in life they'll always be
learning i like to say
learning experiences right they'll
always be learnings but then
how um do we translate that into growth
how do we ensure that that is what we
need to kind of
um bring us forward um to leapfrog us
into the next stage of our lives
and welcome sarah from egypt um
and this brings us to our next slide
it is your reaction to adversity not
adversity itself that determines how
your life story will develop
this is one of my favorite quotes
because it reminds me that
life will happen you know challenges
will happen some of us have
had a really tough year some of us have
you know kind of breached through but i
think i feel like
in some aspect all of us have been
somewhat touched or affected by the
happenings
of um of this year
and so what how do we react to it
what do we take out of it to make sure
that we are empowered
to make sure that we have learned to
make sure that we can look back
on this positively instead of um
you know from a space of of
of disappointment or a space of
depression or space of giving up
which is uh the the other option
so i'd like to open it up um for some of
you to tell me what has been your
biggest
takeaway from 2020 what has been your
biggest experience what's been your
biggest takeaway
what you know in one you know if you can
sum it up in one quick sentence what has
been
what has 2020 meant to you
and again you're welcome to unmute
yourself or you can type in the chat and
i'd
love to hear your responses and
for me um my biggest takeaway from 2020
is um really that i am stronger
than i knew that i could be um i
my a big takeaway from me was just how
much
i love the time and space of quiet
um i love being able to have that
balance where
everything was kind of taken away and i
really had to just sit
and sit with myself and um and review my
life
and what it was that was important to me
and a lot of things that
were no were not important kind of
dropped off
right we thought that our lives revolved
around travel
and work and things like that and when
that was taken away overnight
um i definitely came into an awareness
that of what was really important in
life
and what wasn't so i'd love to hear from
a few of you on what some of your
biggest takeaways from 2020 are and it
it can be positive it can be negative it
can be anything
but um but i'd love to hear at least a
couple
and again you're welcome to unmute
yourself and
um speak up or you can
type into the chat hey i'm man can i
speak
hey and yes welcome um so
i am 45 years old i work in the
education industry right now
just as a tutor but you know at my age i
kind of wanted to
start something new um something
different so i spent this whole year
like learning about programming
something i haven't really done in 20
years
and learning about machine learning and
i'm still just you know learning but
i've completed
so many courses this year and everyone's
like oh 2020 is the worst year
um i got this udacity scholarship i've
completed probably
30 plus coursera courses hopefully in
the future i'll be able to
you know use it so it's just basically
been the year of learning for me
wow that's amazing and thank you for
sharing
and yes honestly this slow down we saw
such an
uptick in the number of people that are
enrolled for our you know for udacity
courses for crosses
for courses across the board so for a
lot of us this was a great time to
really upskill
and and expand you know expand our
knowledge expand our skill base
try new things so that's amazing thank
you um
and then abdul rahman says i had
extra time saved which i used to spend
to travel to office was able to complete
some online courses so again
very much along the same lines where
you're able to participate in a
hackathon
you're able to do those online courses
all from time savings
i think that's a big one for companies
is
really realizing that we don't need to
have
everyone working from the office and so
much
productivity can come from allowing
people to work from home
and you know it's savings it's savings
all around you know it's a time savings
it's a financial savings um so that's
great
um rachel mentioned that with so much
external distraction removed i realized
i have a lot of
work getting clear on my own goals and
priorities on a deep level until i did
that i would struggle to focus on
completing my courses that's an
excellent awareness rachel thank you for
sharing but and yes
sometimes we're so inundated with the
busyness of life that we're not
able to focus on what is most important
and so this time away this time in
isolation this time in quarantine is
really a great time to be able to
do that inner work um
abhishek being at home most of the time
kind of a downside
i hear you on that um yes i
there were times when i felt i was going
absolutely crazy and i literally had to
get into my car and just drive around
but yeah it you know it can be also be
very isolating which is the downside of
it so i definitely hear you
um sarah my biggest takeaway from 2020
is that i've
been through a lot this year and somehow
managed to survive and i also started a
new career in data analysis and
graduated with the nano degree from
udacity again
great accomplishment and shows you that
it doesn't matter
what adversity you might face it's all
about
your reaction to it so yes
you know and some only have strength to
just
you know sit and watch netflix and and
kind of float through the year while
others and where most of you and
and i'm sure this applies to most
udacity students is you really took that
next step to
seeing how you can improve yourself see
how you can make the career pivot see
how you can learn more
so excellent excellent i really
appreciate all the responses and really
enjoyed
reading them and hearing from you so
i'd like to run a poll next
and um to really see
what some of your um
what how you started the year
were did you have clear goals
or was it kind of like you know you kind
of knew in your mind what you do but you
hadn't really set your goals
so i'll go ahead and run a poll
and if you could just respond if you had
clear career goals set at the start of
or maybe you did kinda you had them in
your mind but you hadn't really you know
created a clear pathway or no
not at all
okay okay i'm seeing the responses come
in
so great so it looks like we have
majority
at about the 75 percent
um space which is the kinda which most
of most of us
i i included um until i realized the
importance of clear
the importance of clear career goal
setting um
kind of fell in for most of my life and
so and then yes 25
which is amazing so yeah so that was a
good mix
and so i'd like to have a follow-up
question for the 25
actually for all of you um since most of
you are either yes or kind of
how did you do with those
goals let me see if i can go to the next
slide
and then do the second hole okay
so how do you feel you achieved the
goals that you set for 2020 for those
who are the kindest for those who had
the
they had clear goals um did you smash
them are they still a work in progress
or were you completely derail things to
covet
and everything else that happened this
year
okay okay so i think we have about 11
participants so out here i'd love to
hear from all of the whole group um
okay so it looks like a lot of you are
um still a work in progress for about 75
of you um which is good um and then
completely derailed is 25 so very
similar
okay thank you for your feedback
um
yeah so that's um i just wanted to share
with you the whole results i didn't do
it before
but let me close that out
so again our success rate for goals
very much comes from us
really setting goals clearly and this is
part of the reason why i set up this
webinar
how can we close out this year strong is
by first
looking at how we started the year
reviewing
where we started from okay 25 of you had
very strong goals 75 percent of you had
you know somewhat okay goals
um but not really strong and
and and we saw that in the results and
mind you we had a lot of things
come that kind of were stumbling blocks
and more hurdles
but if we had a higher percentage
of you who had set clearer goals it
would have been easier to achieve them
at the year at the
you know now at the end of the year so
looking back to 2020 uh
how can we look at what we've done what
we've been able to achieve
where we felt short and really just
doing an exercise where you're sitting
down
and writing everything you know and this
is
uh mostly for you kind of who kind of
had kind of goals set but not if you can
go back
and review what they were if you didn't
write them down try and recall
everything that you had wanted to do at
the beginning of the year um and you can
do this
this is great for career but you can do
this across your life as well because it
will support you in your career
so at the beginning of 2020 what was it
that i wanted to do
and list them all out and then think
about
out of that list what was i able to
accomplish
check those off what was i not able to
what were my hurdles what were my
stumbling blocks
what could i have completed regardless
of the
um hurdles and stumbling blocks so
really looking
at that list and then seeing what you
could have done
what you should have done and it's not
anything from a space of regret but just
making sure that you don't repeat the
same thing
as we're going into 2021. so really
we're setting up for 2021 by
reevaluating 2020
learning from it right so it's a great
learning opportunity
and then you can see what is in your
control to change for 2021. so we had
variables
this year that um did not allow
you know for example didn't allow us to
get to work didn't allow us to network
in the way that we
uh were used to networking might not
have allowed us to start a job that
receptive you know
there was a lot of variables that were
out of our control
but there's also even more that
um that are in your control and so it's
coming into
2021 knowing that yes there's a lot that
might we don't know what
what's coming right we don't know if a
second third wave is coming we don't
know what the economies are gonna look
like
but there is still a lot that you can
focus on and we need focusing on what
you can change and what is in your power
and great examples before is okay we
have all this time now
let's learn let's grow let's upskill
let's you know
do what it is we need to do to get to
this next stage
um so now we come to one of my favorite
quotes what you focus on grows
what you think about expands and what
you dwell upon determines your destiny
and this is by robin sharma and
um this is also something else to think
about as you're re-evaluating your year
2020. what did you focus on the most
this year
did you focus on your growth did you
focus on your career did you focus on
your family and just
think back to what it was that you
focused on the most
what you thought about the most what you
dwelled upon the most
and what you should come to find is um
[Music]
it really has an impact in the direction
that our lives take
in whether we see things
as positive or not so positive really
very much
depends on what we focus on and
sometimes yes life will hit us hard
but then there are some people who from
those challenges they're able to still
focus on the positive what positive can
i take out of this how have i grown
as a result of this one of you mentioned
i realize that i'm stronger
than i thought i could be at that was
the same for me like i
was in this situation that i never
thought i could be in and i was able to
navigate it you know
and come out of it pretty unscathed you
know and
and so i came in i came out of it or
you know coming through it with a level
of awareness
as to my own strengths so focusing on
that rather than
all the places that i may have fallen
short you know there were
so many projects that i wanted to do
this year that i wasn't able to do
you know there are so many um aspects of
my life that i wanted to improve that i
didn't but by but not giving that so
much focus because what happens is
sometimes we give so much focus on what
we're not able to do that we just give
up
and we give up on the things that we do
want to do and just realizing that there
will always be
aspects of us that will be needing
improvement so focus on what we're doing
well and then keep building from there
so i'd love an opportunity to hear from
you again how do you
feel about 2021
do you feel are you going in with
excitement
are you going in with some pessimism how
prepared you feel for 2021 from a career
perspective
and again feel free to unmute yourselves
and and
come on or you know share in the chat
i'd love to hear from
one or two of you
actually all of you if possible
all right and just some you know for
some for me
for example how prepared do i feel
um i'm still in the kind of stage where
yes and part of the reason for me doing
um this
workshop is because this is a process
that i'm going through right
this last quarter of the year i really
use it to re-examine
what i've done what i've been able to
accomplish what do i want to set up so i
really plan the next couple of weeks
especially with us being you know having
some time off for thanksgiving
and those of us here in the u.s and just
holidays in general i'm really just
working
on setting the tone for 2021
setting my goals seeing what's important
and again really coming from that
evaluation so
are any of you able to share um how you
feel
just in general it doesn't even have to
be how prepared you feel but just how do
you feel about 2021
well for me i think it's just still
another year of learning and you know
kind of a little bit of pessimism about
will i get a job but
okay i'm going to 2021 hoping to learn
more
you know as you know
got it got it that's great um thank you
so frida says keep going stay busy
that's excellent
um i uh sarah i think the new year will
be surprising for me as my life will
completely change i'm getting married
next month and i'm starting a career in
research and data
analysis wow congratulations sarah and
that's amazing and
yeah definitely lots of beautiful new
beginnings and surprises
so that's awesome and then abhishek i
feel
i'm more prepared than i was in the
beginning of 2020 about career
transition
i have a mixed feeling which is normal
um
excellent excellent thank you for those
of you who shared
so let's go into the next slide how do
we
set up our roadmap for 2021
setting the tone right how we do how do
we do that now
so again re-strategizing reviewing our
year reviewing 2020
looking at what we've done looking at
what we could have done looking at what
we want to do differently
and then really setting up strong
a strong vision and then setting up
goals around that for 20
years so many of you um
and i'm also very guilty of that is
um i don't spend enough time
really getting clear on my vision and
goals you know
and any aspect of my life where i don't
do that in the beginning
my results are always mixed at the end
so if you want 20 you know
you want to think in advance right in
november of 2021
you know if you were sitting at this
webinar again and you were thinking
about
20 you know the year in review what do
you want to be able to say differently
what more do you want to be able to
speak about that you've been able to do
right and that comes from setting your
vision you know some of you mentioned
that yeah you know i'm going into the
new york
apprehensive you know i have all these
changes coming
so a lot of it is okay you know it's
kind of wait and see
wait and see what the year will bring
for me but where
is your responsibility in that how
are you going to create you know and we
have so
much creative power so how do i want my
year to look like
how do i want my first quarter second or
third or
fourth quarter one of you mentioned
continuing
in learning continuing growing that
that's excellent
so what will that look like at the end
what is your
ultimate goal you know at the end of the
year do you want to have
reached a certain certification or do
you want to have reached a certain level
of of understanding technically you know
so
really thinking about what is my
vision for 2021 and creating that in
mind
perfect if i could create the perfect
year
what would that look like you know and
really creating from that space
this is also a great time to look at
your application materials so your
linkedin your
github your any portfolio websites you
have
your resume have they served you in 2020
is there anything that you could do
differently
um is it something that you need to
completely you know do
over that's now is a great time to look
at that
building skills we talked about that you
know and
most of you being at udacity and doing
that already
how about preparing for interviews you
know how can you start
building the technical skills
interview skills the um behavioral
interview skills
whatever it is that you need to come to
show up
and come even stronger if some of you
are looking to pivot and looking for
jobs next year
another key aspect of your career is
continuing to expand your network
we're going into a slower time in the
year um in most of the west you know
with the holidays and all that coming up
now is the time to really use the space
to
continue expanding your network just
because you know there might not be as
many jobs or you know things might have
slowed down on the work
and now is the time to take advantage of
of that time
and um and really expand your network
reach out to contacts you haven't talked
to in a while
make new connections etc
so um and again thank you for your
contribution for you 2020 besides
learning you want to work on personal
projects so get her projects more
applying what i've learned
and have portfolio projects excellent
one of the key things that we hear from
our
students who are successful and from
some of our employers
is um they really look at your
portfolios
and seeing how you're able to translate
your experience and what you've learned
into a portfolio in projects one it
builds your confidence two it builds
your skills and three it's really a
showcase
for who you are what you've done and
what you're capable of so that's
excellent and thank you for sharing
um so let's go on to the next slide so
this is probably one of my
most favorite aspects of
goal setting envisioning honestly a few
years ago you told me goals as soon as
you said the word gold
i just started yawning and for me
the thing that really changed it for me
is
instead of using goals i said what is my
intention
so think about what is your intention
for 2021
what do you what do you intend for your
career life what do you intend for your
personal life you know and so if
you struggle with goals the word goals
like i do
um then that's a great starting point
and the first space in goal
setting is visioning so this is a
powerful exercise that really helps you
hone
into what you really want um
and for most of us we are so
disconnected from this
and for me it literally reminded me of
when i you know first learned that the
power and the importance of visioning
in in goal setting or intention setting
i re i was reminded from my childhood
and how i had such an
amazing imagination and i wanted to
conquer the world you know today i'd
wake up and i wanted to be a doctor
tomorrow i'd wake up and i wanted to be
a flight attendant because i wanted to
travel the world
the next day i wanted to be a an
astronaut you know so
every day i would wake up with this
grand vision for my life and then i
would literally go on and imagine what
it would look like i had a very active
imagination back then and i would
imagine what it would feel like to just
be in the airplane and jet set to all
these different places and all these
different countries and
what it would feel like being there and
experiencing all the different cultures
and literally i later on did that you
know i started when i was in university
and
have gone on to travel most of my career
and that came from me
setting that initial seed when i was
visioning when i was so young and it was
so strong and it was so important to me
that it became a goal it became an
intention for my life that just
came to me so this is really the
starting point for you
so what do you really want for 2021 it's
good to
go off a list like okay i want to
complete this i want to do that i want
to you know
have a checklist but what do you really
want how do you want to
feel do you want to feel accomplished do
you want to feel intellectually
stimulated
do you want to feel you know what is it
that you want to
feel for the year what is it that you
want what is most important to you you
know
and then really from here you can
approach your goals
creatively with a big picture mindset as
to what is most important for me
and then what do i need to do to get
there
so um so this has been used
successfully through history you have
you know
for example i'm not sure how many of you
might have watched
um the the um steve jobs documentary
where he's
you know he had this vision for this
closed system
and he literally got fired from apple he
started another company that was a fail
and then he came comes back to apple
everyone thought he was crazy
but he kept with his vision he had a
vision
and that was his big picture and that's
what led his life until he was able to
break it
walt disney the same thing you know you
look through history
all the great minds they had a vision
that was unshakable so
it starts not with the goals but with
the vision what is the vision for what
you learn to achieve
so this you can do it for your bigger um
goals in life your bigger life purpose
but then
you can also use it for your year so
what how do you envision your year going
through
uh next year what is your big picture at
the end of the year and then break that
up
what would you like to be feel by the
end of q1 by the end of q2 by the end of
q3 by the end of q4 and then break that
down into months
and then build from there so
this brings up to the next slide i'm
sure a lot of you have heard
of um smart goals um
so i like to use even smarter goals
which have like two additional sections
but really creating goals you have to be
specific and again coming back to our
first poll and i asked you did you
have clear goals set for 2020.
75 of you said kinda right 25
of you said yes so for those who
want to be in the yes category for next
year for 2021
you need to ensure that you have created
smarter goals
so they need to be specific details are
important
okay so not just oh i want to pivot
careers
right i want to i want to move
into a data scientist role within this
industry
by this day you know so you need to be
very specific about what you want
because one of the
key um areas that we really fail when
we're setting up goals
is really not being specific enough and
so the more vague you are
the more likely unlikely you are to get
there and i always think about it think
as your goal as the
gps that you as the address that you're
putting into your gps
if you put in a city yes it can get you
to chicago
but then how do you get around chicago
chicago is huge
you know but if you put in an address a
building
a number a city a state a zip or you
know
whatever it is the more detailed you're
able to get the more
likely you are able to gonna get to the
destination that you want so think about
the same with goals
whenever you're creating a goal that's
the address they're putting into the gps
would you
want right and the clearer you can be
the more likely you will be to get to
the destination that you want which is
the achievement of your goal
they need to be measurable you need to
be able to quantify
progress and really
you know so how do you quantify you know
like
so if something is important to you how
do you quantify your progress
right so you can say i want to have
written 50 of a book by
you know q1 of next year so what what
does that mean what is 50
i have to have defined what how many
pages would my book be my book could be
10 pages
so 50 is 5 pages my book can be 300
pages right and 50
is 150. so i need to be able to quantify
my progress so it needs to be
measurable it needs to be achievable
right because sometimes um
we say i want to be a
i'm trying to think of something crazy i
want to be an astrophysicist
this does not align with who i am you
know i
you know as much as yeah it's a cool
thing to be i'd love to be an astronaut
in space but i know i don't
i have no interest in science you know
and
i've never enjoyed the subject and what
it would take for me to get there is not
something that's really of interest to
me so
is your goal achievable your inner and
out of beliefs need to be alignment
with your goal is it relevant and
relatable to you so sometimes you set
goals for other people
or that other people have set on us but
then coming back to
is it relevant for you time based you
should have an assigned
time to each to each of your goals so i
want to have it completed by
the end of 2021. i want to have it
completed by
february of 2021 so really and and also
having smaller goals but sometimes we
put these big goals
and then we don't create the smaller
milestones in order to get to them so
making sure that
um is time based and then the two
areas to add to smart goals is really
being able to evaluate
because this is what keeps you going so
a lot of times we'll
you know write our goals down at the
beginning of the year completely
by mid-year we've forgotten where that
list is we don't even know where it is
if i asked you to find
you know whatever you created for 2020 a
lot of you might not be able to find it
so
really being able to come back to it on
a regular basis
so every month every week
every day you have to look at how you're
progressing through your goals
and then reward yourself you know a lot
of times we don't feel like we've
accomplished a lot because we're not
checking off things as we go along we're
not achieving
we're not um rewarding ourselves but
every goal
every milestone should be rewarded so
the
most goals fail because they were not
created smart you know so goals really
are dreams with a deadline
you know we talked about visioning
visioning that's where we dream we drive
our lives so then gold is kind of like
adding structure and a deadline around
it
you know and obviously the more specific
you are
the easier it will be to quantify so
really coming back to
what action can you take what do you
want to do
and what and how can it be accomplished
so bringing together visioning and goal
settings
it's important to not only know your
goals but to
write them on paper right one we created
our minds and then
actually being able to note it down
think about it this you know the
visioning exercise is great to do when
you relax
when you're in a space of you know just
set an hour or two for yourself to just
wow
sit there and just play with your
imagination and then from there
write write it out you know write out
everything that
came up for you you know and then
and then the keys in envisioning what
that would look like so someone
you know sometimes we think about oh i
want to have my phd
and whatever so but what would that look
like what would that feel like
i need to envision myself walking down
the
um you know the stadium to get my degree
i need to envision what it would look
like working in that space
that requires me to work where i needed
my phd
i need to envision what it would look
like then you know just learning and
gaining the experience
i need to envision what it'll look like
having doctor ahead of my name so those
are just
some examples of what envisioning that
would look like
every great thing was first created in
the mind then got into existence by
sticking to the big picture
which is the vision no matter the
obstacles so the clearer you are
so if i'm constantly thinking about what
it will
look like what it will feel like when
i'm graduating when i'm walking across
down that you know aisle with to get my
degree
as long as i have that big picture in my
mind as i'm going through the hurdles
of research and i'm going to the hurdles
of failing classes you know
and again i can keep coming back to my
big picture of why it is that i'm doing
what i'm doing
so this is again very big picture but
it's very helpful for you setting your
goals and also thinking about next year
how do you want to feel at the end of
the year
you know and then bringing that back
so i've done a lot of talking
so i'd love to hear um what some of your
thoughts are
where you have used visioning and goal
setting to achieve your goals in the
past
and you may have done this all you know
for those of you who are not familiar
with this process
um i would love to hear where maybe some
of you might have used a similar process
to achieve something in the past or even
currently
and again feel free to unmute yourself
feel free to
share in the chat but i'd really love to
hear about a success story or an example
and
when you've used visioning or goal
setting to achieve your goals
okay anyone
um hi hi
so um something that i learned
maybe from from last year was that i did
have those goals and i didn't really
want to achieve them
and i laid out a plan like a
um i know i need to learn 60 hours in a
month to get
there and there and try to make a time
plan with my full-time job
to to say okay if i get up at five in
the morning and learn for
one and a half hours i can get my weekly
schedule in
but then coveted and my
full-time work hours got longer and
longer and it was
more hard and hard to to go after that
um envisionment and that planning that i
did beforehand so that was
kind of a setback and quite frustrating
because i had everything laid out and
if you um for me it was
i knew i have to learn at least one hour
a day
to to make constant progress but
after the months and months progressed
and my work got
more and more intense um i'm one of the
analysts
having to detect covet and patience so
wow my work days got crazy and
and it's it's really frustrating to to
not
tick the box at the end of the day and
be like
okay i i didn't do that here
so i think my biggest takeaway for
2021 is actually to shift the focus
again to growing and
make progress in programming and my
boyfriend and i actually laid out a plan
for 2021
a little timeline what we want to
achieve
also um we laid out financially what
what we have now what we will have in
three months
just to to also know how much of a
cushion
both of us have to if if work
really becomes too crazy to eventually
step back
or to re reduce hours and
and just to recalculate if we can afford
this or not
so for us for 2021
um of course a bit scared still
but um i'm
really glad that we laid this out for us
so i can see now again okay in
december we have this this this coming
up
also like sarah we want to get married
relatively soon look at that i love that
yeah corbin is making or breaking a
relationship again
yes anyone who survived covet i think
you're good to go for a long time
yeah so i think um
i'm from from this
uh get together here i'll take away even
more
ideas to to plan out my year
and to maybe give myself a little visual
above my
my working table too to really focus on
my growth
instead of the growth of my company
because i think
that was the the big setback that really
um yeah was
kind of destroying my personal progress
yeah yeah yeah no i totally hear
katharine and thank you so much for
sharing that
um and you know going and i would love
to just go back really quickly
to setting smarter goals
one of the key things is to evaluate
right
and one of the aspects of evaluating is
evaluating your progress
regularly yes but also seeing how you
may
need to change those goals or make them
realistic because
you can go into 2021 thinking that oh
this is what my year is going to want to
look like i'm going to save this much
i'm going to do this to do that and then
2021 comes up
and then something comes up that you
hadn't expected like it did in 2020. so
how can you
then adjust re-evaluate okay
do my goals still make sense do i will
am i really able to commit to a hundred
hours of learning no
but being with the new situation that
i'm in i can commit to 10 hours
because you want to still feel like
you're contributing towards your goals
but then the aspect of evaluating
is really looking at your progress and
seeing okay i'm not
able to reach this because of other
expand of
external factors that are outside of my
control but then what can i do
internally so that way at the end you're
not feeling like
oh i failed at it no i was able to make
an adjustment
and still was able to achieve my goals
even with the hurdles that came up does
that make sense
uh yeah that that absolutely makes sense
i think that that
was what kind of destroyed
my motivation in the long run as well
because i never
really evaluated it is actually feasible
for me to do is this something that i
can't keep up doing because of course
the motivation is still there
yeah but it was mostly about beating
myself
up because i couldn't match those goals
exactly and whenever you find yourself
beating yourself up that means that
you know realistically that you know
again that
the goal at the time you felt that it
was achievable but things have
changed not to let it so so right so
whenever you find yourself beating up
beating yourself up just go back to the
rear you know
space okay so this is what i had planned
this is what i would like to do
but reality in reality this is what i
can do so that way you're still moving
along and you don't
you know give up the goals all together
and actually that's the reason why most
goals fail
is people they start with oh i'm gonna
go to the gym
every day five days a week from the
start of the year and that it's not
realistic you know by the end of january
everyone has stopped going to the gym
because it wasn't realistic so
but two weeks in they had said yeah five
weeks is a little much
it's too much for my body it's too much
what if
i start with two days a week and then
after a month within three days and then
keep evaluating
there so thank you that was a great
example i've also
gotten some great feedback in the chat
so abdul you recently
switched your job internally to a data
analyst after re-skilling that is
great after learning for 250 years and
now your goal is to prepare profile and
start
interviewing again um so you're having a
little bit of inhibition
and that's normal you know and i still
have challenges with interviews so
that's great we're here to support you
you can set up the one-on-one session we
have great interview advice
um on our careers youtube channel so
uh do we can definitely support you with
that um
frida is learning how to use that
positive attitude convince the hr person
to hire you
yes and there's also a lot of skills
that we can teach you as well so freedom
if you have any one-on-one sessions
definitely schedule with us or come into
the career or to the student path and
ask
or you can direct message me and i can
send you some resources around
that and just really building your
confidence it's not really about
convincing an hr person but just being
able to speak to your strength
and align with a company that values
your strengths
um sarah said adding a degree to my
education section was something i could
pursue and imagine if you was here and
it's happening
amazing that's an amazing um
way of visioning and goal setting and
evaluating yeah
we'll talk about values big and then
rachel revaluing recapping both
to be realistic i didn't do this well
this year adapting on the fly
amazing i love all the feedback you guys
are right on point
so awesome thank you and
one thing i just wanted to say the
visioning piece it's so
important what will it feel like you
know so katarina coming back to you
go you said you had some financial goals
with your uh boyfriend or your fiance
um you how will it feel at the end of
three months you have the amount of sick
money that you saved
how what will it feel like for you will
that give you freedom will you give
yourself
peace so really connect to the emotions
and
feelings that that vision is bringing
you
you know so picture seeing the money in
your account right and
picturing how that will feel for you
because that also really helps us
connect to the goal in an even uh bigger
way
so we have a few more slides to get to
but we're
almost at the end um because i really
want to have
a few minutes for q a so to get started
really you start by taking inventory of
where you are
versus where you want to be so where you
are in your life in your career life and
anything that you're working towards
and then where you want to be and then
start now
procrastination is the killer of
most of our goals and dreams so what can
you do
immediately after this call um what is
something small you can do i don't care
if it takes five minutes but what is
something that you can do to really
start setting yourself up for what you
want
okay um again unleashing your
imagination
and ambition putting your reservations
aside
dreaming and visioning from a big place
like you want to have big dreams not
from limitation not oh yeah because of
kobe i won't be able to get that dream
job no
you are visioning from a space of
limited life ugh i can never say the
word unlimitedness
you know and um and then
bringing that into goals or intentions
okay and so but it's starting
we talked about that um progress
obviously accountability is a big deal
for goals as well to ensure that um
you have the steam the fuel to keep
going
so find an accountability partner
sometimes for me
it helps when i make it public you know
so i might post on my
um facebook that this is what i'm doing
and this is what i plan to do or if you
have someone who you know can hold you
accountable to
meeting those or if you can get a coach
but it's
accountability is one of them the ways
that you can really increase your
chances of meeting your goals and also
being able to write them down even if
you don't want to share them with
anything
with anyone writing them down and being
able to come back to it
holds you accountable because at the end
of the day you either are going to check
after you completed it
or you didn't and then reassessment we
talked about that re-evaluation as
you're going along
and then breaking goals into milestones
so yes
i want to complete my phd but it's not
going to happen overnight
you know so what can i start doing today
i can start looking into programs
right and then what can i do next month
i can start the application process and
what can i do the following
you know like so there need to be
milestones for me to get to what it is
that i need to get to so break it down
you have the bigger goal
but then break it down into bite-sized
pieces
and um and i know we've kind of covered
this already a few of you posted in the
group which i really appreciate is
but one of the takeaways that you can
take from this call is
what is the number one thing you want to
achieve for 2021
come what may you know i don't care if
you know we have
you know whatever may come what is the
most
important thing to you and that will
come from you writing down everything
that you want to achieve
and then what is your most important of
your top three and then knowing that
that's where you need to put
all your focus in because sometimes we
have so many goals
but then we're not able to achieve any
of it because
we were just we're overwhelmed you know
so that's one thing to really come back
to
is what is the one thing you want to
achieve what are the top three things
so that way you know where to focus your
attention and then everything else
um yes can get priority but then you
know most of your energy and attention
should be going to that one or the top
three or the top two or whatever
it might be for you um
and then bringing it back together now
is the time to set the foundation for
the coming year
not january 1 not mid-december now
now is the time to really start working
on that so i'm so glad that all of you
showed up today i'm so glad that all of
you already thinking about
what you've done this year what you've
been able to accomplish what you haven't
and how you can
um bring that in really setting you up
for next year
focusing on the positives how you can
use this year as a launch
pad for next year focus on positive
takeaways because again
what we focus on grows what we give
attention to is what manifests in our
life
so focus on the positive yes we we
came across a lot of challenges as a
collective
but then let's look at the good create a
vision then set goals around the vision
for 21
what you focus on grows choose carefully
and again
this is so important because you want to
be you want to have the power of what
happens in your life
so that brings us to the end of our
presentation
um i would like to give you uh you know
about
three minutes to you know to ask any
last questions that you have i'd really
hope to have a little bit more time for
q a but
um i'm glad that we were able to have a
lot of participation so i really
appreciate all of you doing that
but any questions for me
before we close out
and again feel free to unmute yourself
or um you can type in the chat
okay sarah
okay
and as we wait for sarah's suggestion i
would like to
um for anyone who'd like to go deeper
like i just did a very high level
overview of career
uh you know visioning and goal setting
but if you really want to go deeper i
did a webinar on just
this um subject it's on youtube um on
our
uh on udacity's uh career i've been also
feel free to go on there and listen to
it that can
once you start the exercise of really
planning out your year
um that would be a great place to start
so i will post a
link for it in the chat and the name of
the webinar was setting up for career
success with visioning and goal setting
and this is what i
speak about from the beginning to the
end so that will be a great
next point for you to go deeper and then
if you really want to work through this
process feel free to set up a one-on-one
call with us because those of you who
have
who have career coaching sessions so
sarah says i'm grateful for this call
because i'm finding people
like me mentality-wise yes sarah so
many of us are in the same boat when it
comes to the challenges that we have
when it comes to our viewpoints in life
so it's really
great to participate and that's why i
love sharing all of your examples
because you
ended up seeing i could have spoken the
whole time but
it's in all of you opening up you were
able to see the similarities and
challenges
and even similarities and
accomplishments of the two wonderful
um couples that are going to be getting
married this coming year and all the
successes that we've had
so i and that comes from the courage to
open up because sometimes it can be a
little bit challenging so
um i really like this call to be
repeated and i want all of us to
communicate once in a while that's great
sarah we have
a um a student hub channel where
you can ping me and we can i can always
set up a follow-up to this call
on if you you know if you find that
important we do have the weekly amas
every tuesday um that's a great point so
you're welcome to join that
as well i i used to be on there
regularly but lately i've been a little
bit busy
but um we always have amazing career
coaches on there
and that brings me actually to the next
slide join us for future webinars
um we have them on udacity.com events
we have a weekly ask me anything on
tuesdays at 9 00 a.m
pacific time 12 eastern time us
feel free to connect with other students
and share information
there's also the student hub where you
can do that we have
um you know we have career hotlines
where you can answer
any questions that you have so i really
hope that this has been helpful to all
of you
um it's been really i've really enjoyed
speaking with all of you make sure you
check that um check out that
webinar sent out it's in the chat and
yeah
have a great rest of the weekend and
enjoy your holiday season for those of
you who
um will be will be
um who are celebrating holidays so sorry
i was reading i was trying to read and
talk at the same time
so sarah great suggestion yvonne is
udacity doing a pro
is doing program study groups or is
there a forum for finding accountability
buddies
again you can do that in your classroom
um so they should you should be able to
chat with your peers
um who are taking the same course these
are 30 days of udacity where you can do
that
there's a student hub channel where you
can just ask hey is anyone looking for
an accountability
uh partner so we don't have set up
systems for that
but um but they're definitely channels
where you can use that
so i'm so glad that this was worthwhile
thank you again everyone and have a
great rest of the weekend
thank you
thank you very much thanks